the illegal paintings spreading
subversive and hostile messaging over
the last few weeks across london
are not the work of several people as
was originally believed
but the work of an individual the
criminals
authorities recommend not to approach
the individual
first they came for the foreigners and i
did not speak out
because i was not a foreigner
then they came for the protesters
and i did not speak out because i was
not a protester
then they came for the journalists and i
did not speak out
because i was not a journalist
[Music]
[Music]
and then they came for street artists
i did not speak out
because i am not a street artist
now realized that eventually they'd come
for me
and there would be no one left to speak
for me
[Music]
i'll show you the way okay sorry [ __ ]
jesus all right so we're in a total mess
now let's get the hell out here
after a long night london is in
chaos the main artwork
well well well welcome to the resistance
there's a welcome gift for our new
members
but the disappearance of the criminal
players he could have told me it was a
bloody
costume partly try it off the new key
suspect has been identified as david
ford
a 43 year old london taxi driver he has
no criminal record but is currently
believed to be a terrorist
people have been asked not to approach
him the authorities advise all residents
[Music]
you